the jurogan experience what does it feel
like
yeah look it's been pretty crazy you
know obviously on top of the water right
now but yeah
i feel like you're living in a fog like
a dream
a little bit but i've had that vision
you know for so long you know i've
manifested for so long and um
you know before this fight even as a
young amateur i knew i'd be world
champion i knew one day my time would
come and
you know it finally did well i was told
about you a couple of years ago by my
friend vinnie shorman uh who's uh big in
the muay thai world and liam harrison is
a muay thai world champion they were
telling me how awesome you were years
ago
but uh until saturday night of last week
the world you know they didn't know they
had to see it
yeah look uh both great guys and um i
think it was 2018 i was in this in uh
wild card gym sparring
and i'm in the ring and i see these two
guys and they're watching so i thought
you know i'll put on a show for these
guys and let's see they might be someone
that can take it to the next level they
might be promoters who knows so i always
want to put on a show
and they couldn't believe it and then i
knew that they'll comment on your show
when i started speaking to them and when
they dropped my name on it i was like
wow this is amazing now i'm here with
you
well your performance against tia female
was uh spectacular it was amazing and
i mean it was a fight where how much of
an underdog were you coming into that
fight i was a huge underdog you know
seven to one underdog wow you know bet
online.ag had me seven to one so you
know um that just shows the adversity
that you have to come through you could
be a massive underdog but no matter what
you know you get through it and you you
can win whatever you choose to do well
you were undefeated coming into that
fight but you just hadn't faced the same
level of opposition that he had and it
didn't mean that you weren't capable of
it it just you just hadn't had the
opportunity before so it wasn't a seven
to one
like they didn't think you had the
skills it was seven to one that you just
hadn't had that that moment in the sun
before i think because
that's right i haven't had my moment yet
leading into that fight but
you know he was coming off the big long
chenko fight the big win there what he
done in that fight so impressive he
knocked out richard comey as well so
the hype the the noise that he was
making this was just going to be a
normal mandatory fight you know that
took so long to make and um he was
supposed to do the business
and move on to something bigger but
now that hunger that i had you know that
that tunnel vision to show who i am to
show how great i am and i had to go
through it all in that fight you know
from the cuts to being put down around
10 but i knew that this is
my greatness now how good i can be and
show the world and shock the world
it is you definitely did shock the world
it is
a reoccurring theme in boxing and in all
combat sports when someone takes an
opponent lightly
and they go in
thinking they're just going to steamroll
this guy
and then they get met with reality i
mean it's happened so many times
in fighters careers
and then there's also the other
reoccurring theme a guy like yourself
who has his eyes on the prize is
completely focused and people are
counting them out then they rise to the
occasion and become a superstar and
that's what happened to you you see it
many times and i feel that
he didn't take me lightly because he's
in great shape he was in unbelievable
condition
i felt as we led into the fight and we
had that first press conference where we
looked into each other's eyes and i saw
the
you know
a guy who it came too fast and he needed
to be matched with someone that was not
going to take a step backwards and the
whole thing was this whole preparation i
was never going to take one step
backwards i never gave him that that
inch and even in the fight i never gave
him that inch i was always there to be
dominant and i felt like he was it was a
bully kind of character you know where
he bully lomachenko he bullied kami yeah
he bullied all his past opponents
but
you know i've come from bullying i was
an overweight kid at a young age i've
been bullied all my life you were
overweight i was overweight i used to be
135 pounds at like 10 years of age until
i fell into boxing so
you know i knew it straight away i got
okay i know how to stand up to this guy
i know what i got to do in this fight
and he saw how serious i was
so
you know we we stayed focused we kept
the tunnel vision and we uh we done the
business well you did a beautiful job of
boxing him as well i mean you stayed in
the pocket and cut angles you landed
beautiful combinations that one right
hand in the first round though really
set the tone for that fight when you sat
him down at the end of the first and
dropped him and it was just and it was a
hard right hand i mean it was a
beautiful right hand and when you see
his eyes roll back and he drops and he
gets up and he's like what the [ __ ] just
happened
that was a giant wake-up call and it
really set the tone for the rest of the
fight yeah it did um i went into that
that first round i knew he'd be very
emotional i knew he took it so personal
and leading up to the whole fight week
when i kept getting asked is this
personal for you because i knew i knew
it was so personal for him so no this is
business for me and this is just another
fight this is what i love to do doesn't
matter who's in in that side of the ring
for fighting against me and
i knew i had to get his respect straight
away he would come out crazy i stayed
composed i landed some really good short
shots on the on the inside in the first
round and like the great customize i
said to muhammad ali when he fought
george foreman he goes
how am i going to beat this guy how can
i beat this puncher and cuss goes hit
him with the right hand
in the first round him with your best
right hand and show him that hey i can
punch as well and i had that in my head
you know i
have the great book by customato and i
have it highlighted and before i went to
the arena i went over it i showed it to
just have it in my head what a amazing
mind he had
custom models mind for boxing for the
psychology of boxing was just so
incredible
you know and the fact that mike tyson
found that man when he was 13 years old
it's almost like destiny you know and
you know what i i believe that
everything in life is destiny you know i
look at my road to to get to the
championship
it's just it just fall into place but
with destiny you need to work hard you
need to
you know take it in your own hands as
well but everything's meant to be and
that right hand was meant to be and i
said it to my team okay you're watching
the first year i'm going to catch him
early i'm going to hurt him with
something because i knew i was looking
for that right hand and when he came out
crazy and he
you know he was heavy on the front foot
he tried to fake the jab and i saw that
front foot right there i knew his head
wouldn't move
here it is here's that shot i've been
dreaming about my whole life
bang i let it go like a lightning strike
let's take a look at it jimmy show me
that punch because that was just so
beautiful i screamed when i was at home
and i watched it yeah i yelled out i was
by myself i sit in the living room
the whole world just jumped down okay
now we gotta fight because i don't think
many expected me to even stand a chance
in the first round you know they were so
vocal about one round one round
especially his dad
well his dad made a huge bet didn't he
bet a hundred thousand dollars that he
was going to knock you out within two
rounds yeah well i want to find out the
person he better gets because here it is
take a look at this and take it in
nice beautiful left hook well you were
in front of them but you weren't there
that was what was beautiful about it
like your head movement like right there
that angle guys just
gorgeous box here it is
right here baby bake oh my goodness
and i saw it in his eyes as soon as i
landed that shot and he got up he
thought what the [ __ ] was that you can
see it right there he's like whoa yeah
now we're in this flight and then the
the fake smile
i was a little bit off balance
but that shot there was was probably
more devastating than the original shot
and then i'm just going off i had to say
it i said
you know now i'm here one round is that
what you said yes i said one round
okay now we're in a fight
it was an amazing performance